juror who listened to conservative
podcaster timpool here's the AP
journalist juror who listened to
conservative podcaster timpool joined
verdict against Donald Trump they tried
to get him out remove him and he just
went along with it so yeah I'm I'm sorry
like I don't know what you know the
craziest thing to me is when these like
sexual assault claims pop up 30 years
later and people get convicted on it I'm
like what evidence do they have there's
DNA evidence like by all means but
evidence of sex is not evidence of rape
yeah yeah you're seeing ped he's being
smacked around with all these lawsuits
now and ultimately I'm okay with sexual
assault like lawsuits coming about if
there was a criminal case that came
first and they were found guilty in the
courtroom but now we're just we're fast
forward and going straight to to civil
and unfortunately it's because he he
actually P did actually filed well
settled his lawsuit with Cassie his
ex-girlfriend so quickly that three more
I think it's three more accusations
popped up right after that and so now
he's got to battle these three
accusations and there's really I mean
there's very little evidence that you
could bring forward to even prove you're
innocent